fired FBI director Jim Comey still
selling his book was on Meet the Press
over the weekend on the show Comey said
he was not impressed with the houses
Russia investigation because their work
is too political he said watch I think
the most important piece of work is the
one the special counsel is doing now
this strikes me as a political document
did the House Intelligence Committee and
all survey a good investigative purpose
during all this in your observations not
that I can see just totally got too
politicized
yeah and it wrecked the committee and it
damaged relationships with the FISA
Court the intelligence community's it's
just a wreck what an oily false
character he is it's obvious of course
this political document would contrast
completely with the work of the special
and council investigation that initially
employed Peter struck and Lisa page
Congressman Devon Nunez is the chairman
of the House in television in join us
tonight from California so what exactly
if we can sort of work our way through
the can't hear what is the core charge
against this report you said the
president did not collude with Russia to
the best of your knowledge the
counter-argument is what well it's hard
to keep a straight face through that
interview first of all it's softball
after softball it's not a real interview
but most importantly mr. Comey probably
never read our report and likely because
Department of Justice and the FBI
redacted so much of it that if you go
online and try to read our report you
will see that much of it you can't even
read so notice he doesn't know what we
have what so we've been trying to get
Department of Justice and the
intelligence agencies to unredacted the
American people can actually see the
work product that we created I think the
most alarming thing is is that mr. Comey
continues to say that he did not tell us
things that clearly he said on the
record to us like the fact that mr.
Flynn
the agents interviewed mr. Flynn did not
believe that he lied and we want the
American people to see mr. Comey
statement and we can't get that to them
until this until our report is
actually aloud is it allowed to be out
for the American public to see and they
unredacted all so you're in charge of
oversight of the Intel world what did
you make of a statement that former CIA
director Brennan made on Friday when he
appeared to threaten the president over
the mower investigation and said
basically wait till you see what Muller
has on Trump how would the former CIA
director have advanced knowledge of that
how would he know anything more than I
know is a private citizen what is that
well well if that's the case then we're
gonna have another problem because
they've been hiding additional
information from us so we've interviewed
almost all of the people involved in
this I think you know 75 people we've
interviewed we found no evidence
whatsoever of any collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russians as I've
said multiple times before we did find
very clear links between the Russians
and the Democratic Party and so the
people that essentially say that that
Trump has done this and then accused
some of us of being conspiracy theorists
they're the ones they're the ones we
refuse to believe their conspiracy
because we have no evidence of it and
then they deny the fact that they're the
ones that that paid to get information
from the Russians so I think Moeller
should be investigating them really
quickly just as an American if you found
evidence that the president's or his
campaign colluded with a hostile foreign
power would you cover it up no a matter
of fact I've said that from the
beginning I said I'll be the first one
to go out there and tell the American
public look we have clear links between
the Trump campaign and the Russians but
Tucker I'll just repeat again we have
clear links between the Democratic Party
in the Hillary Clinton campaign and the
Russians and nobody reports that well I
haven't seen that on CNN so I'm gonna
have to run it by our fact checkers yes
thank you count on that thank you for
joining us tonight good to see it always
a pleasure